I always normally do time I knew I knew
I knew isn't my cards I knew I wasn't
gonna happen as well do this and get
over that was it
Wow what was it like I'm so I don't know
why I'm fascinated by like what really
goes on in prison could you see moving
in you know movies and TV but I don't
find out really what is it really is
nothing on the outside nothing I I knew
I was going to getting this all I could
wish for was every day that I you know
there was crazy people there even when I
got to I can't then when people do that
business there from Ironman you know
they still have those times and season
now there's a thin line for respected
and the outside and what respect is
inside with people yeah there's a weird
thing in your mind you know there's a
lot so I just kept to myself you know I
had a friend that had gotten into
trouble and I took him off to lunch a
bunch of times
and he hooked me up he calls the prison
and talked to the one guard he knows is
my buddy he was well he was rich this
guy mm-hm
his name is ed kibosh he was a bad
[ __ ] he was a geek that became a
a drug millionaire he started hanging
out with this chick a little about drugs
maybe he made money and then last he
crashed two cars in one week he had a
liquor store my dress for oh yeah he had
two chicks he was hot they were driving
Porsches I mean this guy was banging now
that sounds nice but when he got locked
up he paid a lot of money to get taken
care of he paid a lot leave any people
keep it how it returns you pay money to
get taken care a little bit really like
a couple people just like when I got it
they told me what to do and I thought I
took care of you seem like a guy that
would very quickly move up though and be
running your own little ring no I tried
to keep because you don't want to step
on nobody's toes right when I got to my
final destination yeah I was having a
great [ __ ] time really yeah you
having fun you're the best
you're the first person I've ever seen
they were having fun in jail I mean you
can look there to see [ __ ] ways
to look at it in two [ __ ] ways I know
but you know I was working in a kitchen
had access to food yeah it meant people
want to talk to me because I had access
to food oh yeah cheese to make nachos
they want to do ah they like skins oh
you winking at me on purpose or your
home okay like someone like you know oh
my god those babies okay
yes baby yeah you know yeah guys that
work in the garbage crew yeah for the
drop of a pair panties are the eggs it
over that's the guy favorite yeah I
figure out know like maybe yeah listen
you like to do coke how about I give you
an eight ball okay yeah yeah this spot
is a bag this would be token in for the
dime dirty Danny yeah what they don't
search you you know on the way back or
something just think once you have those
type of jobs people so like I had
friends that would come to me though my
wife brought me tamales broke and you
put them in the freezer for I give me
two right off the top bang oh no I
thought I had access to a freezer now
Huck I had access to a property
60 yards from the main facility so the
guys that were selling steroids and [ __ ]
would save me you have a stash over
there we'll pay you some money you know
was it we asked my heroin so I would put
it somewhere why could you get in
trouble for it why I would put it
somewhere where it's gotten my car but
I'm watching it but not really so there
was crates outside and the garbageman
had to pick him up
I would stash the heroin under a crazy
Sun so nobody got in trouble oh my god
could always be big lobbies man there's
always a risky has always a doubt you
were involved in dangerous activity you
could have been taken out on the inside
oh no I wasn't I was fine it wasn't like
that at all it would like low-level
dudes but a hitter was a high level God
it was there was a guy that was a biker
I became friends but I still think about
he's a solid [ __ ] white dude
solid white dude just white I would
think about I still think about him late
at night uh he used to get mad every
Monday from his girlfriend his
girlfriend would come in and swap spit
with him a condiment and fill it up with
[ __ ] menu yeah like two eight balls
in like a little common every Monday
oh he would pull over here mountain
walking with you know Oliver [ __ ] laughs
they would search him and [ __ ] he
come in and he call me over to his room
and we do a little line at Matt and then
we'd go play basketball in the gym like
I was [ __ ] Julius Erving my heart was
gonna blow up there was no I still think
of those guys total rate piles a black
dude that was a high level [ __ ]
he had seven [ __ ] girlfriend Alicia
Lee had a different [ __ ] Porsche
Mercedes it was amazing on the outside
oh yeah seven girlfriends how long was
he any change he was in there for 12 or
13 years huh what he got man for seven
go ahead he go this [ __ ] was
making cash in there that's great this
is when the Crips were all from
California Colorado and distributing
cocaine do you need seven girlfriend for
in jail there because it was big big
pimping they have conjugal visit
oh well I heard you were to be an
addiction so me and him what you do is
if you have a visit undecided late
Sunday you gonna sit next to having us
but don't worry if I haven't busy that's
the animals if I get a job one day true
Friday
yeah my business is having it I got it
it's tough to be the finger you when
there's 200 animals in the room but if I
take a visible you on Wednesday there's
no baby in the back there's four people
there I do how you come in bring a
basket you're not serious
yes we you're all in the same room so
when you visit somebody I'm [ __ ]
family and son yeah then it's a big room
and you just get on a table you talk so
it's pretty rough for me to finger you
because the 200 people eating is Monday
through Friday if you work in the
kitchen you get visits
so you would say coming Monday and
Tuesday bring a basket of food we'll
have lunch
we're addressing no panties and we would
sit by them I would make you sit by the
door there was a door here and there was
a window so I would make you pop up so
you could see around and I would eat
your [ __ ] while you were looking at the
guards and see if any of the guards were
covered oh yeah there was a scam there
weren't really conjugal visits but their
work on oh yeah I would give you a stab
and every Monday I was giving them
Monday stabbing that secret conjugating
in jail show up on Mondays into the not
conjugal Jane I got it Monday and
Tuesday they would come in and you said
I don't like nothing's happening yeah
bring a dress yeah and we look around
the garden we will pop up that dress
I'll give you a little time a little
sucky sucky and then we talked for two
hours like lemon yeah yeah we eat
Chinese food you can bring food in and
then bring me groceries for the week
they check the groceries and to take a
big laugh the top but that means they
take carrier um saying okay have you
ever loved anyone enough to stay with
them through prison yeah and then not
only will they stay with them they swore
to go in every week [ __ ] yes in jail
that'd be great [ __ ] yes imagine this
imagine if you were with a really great
guy you know and then he did go to jail
for you for something he did that was
like heroic you know like he saved
another girl but he accidentally kind of
killed a guy he lost his temper or
whatever and then he goes to jail and
he's amazing and there's a way that you
can sneak in and have this like faked in
the kitchen like he pays off the guards
sex every once in a while but not have
to deal with all the relationship drama
at home that'd be like a perfect
scenario you know what do you think
these chicks for some airline I have I
meet a prisoner why do you think you
should get together with these [ __ ]
killers a [ __ ] that's the thing I got a
dick in me the guy killed 18 people
people my I went to jail for heroic
reason
sure you got a hookup but I got it to
hero good luck no are you over the
violent dumper huh I'm kidding there's
no such thing as zero you mean like
you're [ __ ] my incubating people no
we don't want to I don't want to we just
we can't help it there's something about
a guide that will kill people that's
like you know it's primal it's like the
man you know it's like the beast inside
we don't really want them to we don't
really want murderers you know